hey guys it's Justine and this is my
sister Jenna today we are prepping for
Easter so we're gonna do all of the
Easter prep work for you so you don't
have to well they can do it too if they
want you don't want to do that oh yeah
you don't want to do this because I
ordered all kinds and okay looks like
I've got a couple of duplicates looks
like I have four simple okay I think I'm
$1 well got half an order four of these
is the question I'm really sure I
ordered a bunch of these apparel a order
duplicates we have a shimmering pearl I
use that boy neon molten magic marble
egg Wow candy-apple egg oh this isn't
good it's been an egg is it that some
little Easter lights and oh I got an
Easter Lego set like did you want to
hang these up before yeah open him up
the best part about this Lego set look
at this little guy he is searching for
Easter eggs he's got a magnifying glass
this is like the coolest thing I've ever
seen you should get out more
you mean is it me as a person I can't
help but imagine existing in this you
know I don't get out a lot so that's
like digging deep that's like no Jeff no
Jeff stupid all right
what should we test first oh I should
probably get the clot what do you need
okay we need cups so tablets yes no what
we need vinegar
you got vinegar you might not have
better girl-- can you fit an egg in here
yes but what I don't have sure do do I
have you I have Minotaur white vinegar
what kind of is Bill I'm holding a thing
a vinegar apple cider though wait I have
some let's test each one of these this
is gonna be the marble one is that a
tablespoon do you think that's a
tablespoon generous
Wow science
this is content yeah okay so what we do
with this one look at that everybody
work here gold Oh blames you just do
those how can I help
okay this came out of here so this is
dazzling color color brilliant tolerant
brilliant this one we just paint them so
let's put this here so this is our
classic color do you need this so we're
gonna move it over here do I need to put
it in here no you're putting another
variable okay okay oops
Wow Wow yeah that's pretty that's pretty
that's pretty you're pretty you're
pretty I'm going to put my egg in the
machine what are you doing over there
I'm I'm spinning an egg okay where's my
packet what colored me one green purple
yes eight to ten drops oh well that was
that's that's all okay place top on
spinner pump the top and watch the egg
spin who's ready for fun
we can get real wild and add more color
it doesn't say that on the packet though
I'm I'm adding my own creative spin oh
my god oh my god humor
this is science pink I don't I am
thinking that like what are you doing
have you made anything yet No
so I'm now adding a pink to my mixture
there's so much going on so I think that
I could probably use all these same
colors because all of these are like the
same that's fine you can do whatever you
want I just have like a lot of people
added extras what fine you're in trouble
everything yes sure
you took this to me okay here we go we
added two colors everyone how much what
in there the machine doesn't then use
the stick have I done it this is
[Music]
extraordinary you're having a like
diamond stuff that's beautiful
okay a gem that has a very bad smell I
don't like I like the smell of that I
realized there's art first I'm not even
I'm even Oh what do we do this oh I need
another dry egg when I told you guys
that I was gonna be reviewing these I
think that you should probably not
expect any sort of review and you should
not listen anything that I say I'm doing
a very good job of this egg spinner with
you I'm gonna add another color I'm
gonna add yellow have you made an egg
yet no I mean it's like Easter 2020 at
this point oh my god
here we go I think I'm just gonna paint
one golden happens this is a gem of an
artwork look at this just oh that is
nice okay I'm gonna paint this gold sir
I was thinking that this would be a
little bit more insulating should I
check to see if there's a murderer here
or like me our batteries oh my god yeah
you're right wow that was fast what do
we need that for again the lights very
important part of this Oh what I'm up
hang up gorgeous glitter at all right
it's a Marvel eh I don't think it's
gonna work out very well here gets that
side I think it looks lovely
all right there's still no eggs that are
made have we made an egg I've made what
did I do it to say this is like clay you
keep it in there new wedded do I have
scissors Oh Michael are you kidding me
I'm leaving I'm going home
it's like watercolor I think it actually
is rejecting water wait a minute what's
happening place the colored wax square
on the egg it place it in the wax it is
a wax I was like it's repellant oh my
god we need a hairdryer turn a hair
dryer on low point warm air Oh
let's use fire no like I'm so lazy to
walk up the stairs to get a hairdryer so
I'm using my brain this is gonna work
but he so I didn't read past what you're
supposed to do after the hairdryer a bit
oh my god that looks incredible that
looks really good so children don't do
this what if the wax burns me okay oh my
god are you all right that's so scary I
don't think this is the best way to dye
eggs these have been in here for an hour
an hour I don't even know what's gonna
happen probably hatched they probably
have hatched on it that's dry oh this is
my marbled egg okay the left
absolutely not even marbled anymore
because it's been in here for so long
too many more paint brushes this is is
that this looks good
I was painting this one pink but do we
have any more paintbrushes okay no more
paint what's this hmm
me upset you need to sit her down I bet
this is exactly how it went down as
children we're doing us screaming at
each other
hey I should we probably got along
because you're white really nice well
now we've really come into our bodies
and our personality hmm okay so stupid
if you thought this is a good idea
oh there we go well that's hot oh that's
hot
oh my god burning my fingers working oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah
[Applause]
I see oh my god Brittany you
[Music]
[Applause]
I think the fire might have been better
lettuce wraps everywhere
[Applause]
[Laughter]
smells this is so stupid
I'm so upset right now
[Applause]
all over everything
well was it worth it I don't think look
at this how bad this is what does this
go Jonah stinks smells like a crayon so
I guess I'm gonna paint this goal so
what do I do with this video that's yeah
yeah I'd like to use that please okay
here you go I think that this went
terribly this is a disaster um we pick
our favorite yeah I think this is my
favorite this one's my favorite
oh look at that sound no I don't think
they made a single egg but look is there
a silver I could like no I don't wanna
ruin it the silver I put inside of why
would you do that how do you get all the
stripes with over well you put them like
[Music]
look at that okay I'm sorry
just helps you a little bit I don't
think that it did I am gonna leave you
now I don't like it the best thing about
this video is that it's over by
[Music]